eingebildete seine steht nach du weißt
ja mama ich komme wisst ihr was ich
feiere euch ihr seid so eine humorvollen
konstruktive freundliche und
intelligente community
es macht mega spaß mit euch und wir sind
sehr dankbar aber ihr wisst das internet
ist nicht immer ein so schöner ort
sondern ein ort wo sich menschen
beleidigen beschimpfen bedroht in einem
maße wie sie es sich in real life
niemals trauen würden oder so hoffe ich
zumindest denn selbst in der
offline-welt schein menschlichkeit und
empathie immer mehr unter den tisch zu
fallen
deswegen heute ein plädoyer für mehr
empathie aus einer wissenschaftlich
philosophischen sicht der mensch ist das
am höchsten entwickelte wesen
aufschließen konnten und seine empathie
also seine fähigkeit sich in andere
menschen hineinzuversetzen ist
wesentlicher bestandteil unserer
geistigen überlegenheit gegenüber
unseren tierischen freunden schön
deutlich wird das 1 2 körperfunktionen
die wir nicht oder nur sehr schlecht
kontrollieren können erstens wir weinen
wenn wir traurig oder sehr bewegt sind
habt ihr schon mal gefragt warum wir
weine also was es für einen zweck hat es
gibt verschiedene arten von training wir
produzieren zum beispiel ständig die
sogenannten pasanen tränen die unsere
augen feucht halten dann gibt es die
sogenannten reflex tränen die auf
irritation reagieren wie zum beispiel zu
beschneiden oder einem fall im auge doch
emotionale tränen sind einzigartig für
uns menschen und es gibt verschiedene
wissenschaftliche theorien warum wir
weinen eine davon finde ich besonders
schön
wissenschaftler glauben dass sich
emotionale tränen evolutionär
durchgesetzt haben weil sie eine
ehrliche auf richtige kommunikation
unsere gefühle sind die wir nicht so
ohne weiteres vortäuschen können
ein körperlicher mechanismus für
ehrlichkeit und aufrichtigkeit
die zweite körperfunktion wir werden rot
wenn wir uns schämen und diejenigen von
euch die schnell rot werden wissen dass
man es nicht wirklich unterdrücken kann
ich wurde werden dich gut werden jetzt
kann man sich fragen was für eine
hochentwickelte funktion soll das denn
bitte sein der mensch
wir waren auf der wohnt wie bauen
quantencomputer und unser gesicht wird
stärker durchblutet wenn wir etwas
verkackt haben aber es ist genauso wie
beim weinen scham ist ein essenzieller
teil von sozialen zusammenleben wir alle
machen mal etwas das nicht so cool ist
wofür wir uns schämen was uns aufrichtig
leid tut und jetzt hat unser körper auch
noch eine funktion diese scham
aufrichtig ehrlich und unfähig ba zu
vermitteln
bei sozialen interaktionen ist es
unglaublich wichtig dass die anderen
nicht nur denken sie jetzt ganz schön
verpackt sondern jetzt ganz schön
verpackt aber sie weiß es auch es ist
fast eine art körperliche entschuldigung
das rot werden also schön schlau von
unserem gesicht
ich sehe das so unser körper hat uns mit
klar erkennbaren signalen ausgestattet
die anderen menschen helfen mit uns
empathisch zu sein nicht in uns hinein
zu versetzen mit uns mitzufühlen weinen
und rot werden 21 menschen einzigartige
körperfunktionen ergebnis von vier
milliarden jahren evolution die uns zu
diesen hoch entwickelten intelligenten
und sozialen wesen macht und die uns
helfen uns ineinander hinein zu
versetzen und miteinander zu treten
starke emotionale und soziale bindungen
waren evolutionär gesehen ein klarer
vorteil ich meine wäre
die ich-form serie an tiger wenn sie
keine freunde hast und heute sind
emotionale und soziale bindungen nicht
immer noch überlebenswichtig was denkt
ihr
sollten wir außerdem unsere
faszinierenden körperfunktionen weinen
und rot wären wirklich unterdrücken oder
uns dafür schämen und brauchen wir mehr
empathie lass uns drüber reden
in den kommentaren damit wünsche ich
euch ein wunderschönes weihnachtsfest
das fest der liebe wenn ihr mir zu
weihnachten einen wunsch erfüllen wollt
dann teilt dieses video ansonsten detlef